okay um next game with some
guy from the united states
let's see okay plays it ambitiously at
least with c4
i go for a line with g6
which is rare but
it's a bit more interesting to play than
the normal lines
okay
at this point he could have played um
knight b5 which is very interesting
yeah of course yeah he chose them
to um to play it
simple and regain the pawn immediately
yeah it looks a bit ugly
for black because of the the default
pressure
but um
it's not easy to see how white can
um profit from that in the near future
because i still have the king to protect
d7
and i also have possibilities of um
putting a knight on d4
of course when the queens are off or the
queen is away from d5
and isn't attacking the rook
so now it's a question what white is
doing now
if he lets me take he also needs to
reckon with
in case of rook takes with his knight b4
e4 c2 okay interesting v5
hmm
okay i cannot take anywhere here
okay let's exchange here
i have an idea maybe it is complete
completely bogus but
idea is if he takes with a rook now i
can just take e5 this should be
should be fine if he takes the pawn
i want to play king d7 and block the
pawn with the king
the bishop is pretty strong on g7
and doesn't allow him easily to to
develop his queen side
and then maybe have rook rook e8
woogie 6 try to get the pawn back
okay he tries to develop now i could
could just play knight to before and
get the spawn
not sure if it's a good idea
because it's really slow
maybe just look to e8 first
if he tries to
play um this one
okay
take here it's got rook a1
but my idea was to go here anyway
to pressurize the bishop
we move some something like um
bishop f4 now i play i play um here
also in this case i play knight d4
now d6 is hanging
yeah okay
can't
yeah he's keeping the pawn but this
bishop
is not doing much and this bishop is
attacking f2
b2 and so on
so i'm not sure
okay interesting moment now i could
now play bishop f6
to get the material back
okay but i could try to
make some more progress before
i didn't take before into account
it's a bit annoying
okay let's prevent this
okay maybe he wants to
take now play rook c7
time warning
maybe rook e3 rook a3
very double-edged position i think
he will sacrifice the exchange here
at some point
now
difficult very difficult position
maybe he can
move the bishop at some point ah this
was stupid
this was stupid now he gets to
seven
ah this was bad black forfeits on time
yeah i played this too ambitiously
at some point yeah b5 was was maybe a
bad idea
i mean black doesn't have any any
problems here because
i could i could just play rook f5 bishop
f6
and get the pawn back it's it's pretty
easy to get the pawn back here
or keep an active position with no
problems but
maybe this was too ambitious
um i need to
to play more x make more exact moves
here
difficult difficult
yeah the computer gives white a half
pawn
yeah well okay